in july of 2014 sheikh khalifa bin zayed
al-nayan the president of the uae
publicly announced the creation
of a national space agency called the
united arab emirates
space agency sheikh khalifa would go on
to discuss the country's goal to put a
probe on mars by 2021
which marked the 50th year anniversary
of independence from britain
at the time this announcement wasn't
taken that seriously
while it was awesome that more countries
were entering the space industry
and that they had massive goals it
seemed impossible for a brand new space
agency to reach mars within 7 years
yet against all odds the uae put their
probe into orbit
around mars on february 9 2021
so here's how the uae not only nailed
their first martian mission
but how they did it on time
taking a look back the uae first
proposed creating a space agency
back in 2008. they weren't looking to do
it by themselves though
they knew that they were a rather small
country entering the industry much later
than
everyone else so they were looking to
form a conglomerate space agency
similar to the european space agency
called the pan arab space agency
however their proposal to create the
conglomerate space agency
was rejected apparently a couple of
middle eastern countries
already had an unofficial space
conglomeration so
it didn't make sense to create a new one
after learning about this
the uae decided to support the
unofficial agency pushing to make it
official
at the 2009 global space technology
forum despite the push though
nothing would really happen over the
next couple of years
given the complacency from the other
countries the uae would decide to just
make their own space agency
in 2014 after all having a national
space agency was far better than
endlessly trying to create
a conglomerate space agency since they
couldn't form a partnership with their
neighbors though
the uae would turn around and form
partnerships with the french and uk
space agencies
in 2015. these european space powers
were far more advanced than the uae
but to say that the uae didn't bring
anything to the table
wouldn't exactly be true you see the uae
had
actually launched seven satellites
before creating a national space agency
the first three of these satellites were
mobile communication satellites built by
boeing in the early 2000s
these satellites were called through one
two and three
and they were launched in october of
2000 june of 2003
and january of 2008 respectively the
next two satellites were built by the
european aeronautic defense and space
company
which is basically just airbus's defense
and space division
these satellites were called alya 1 and
allya 2
and they were launched in april 2011 and
april 2012 respectively
moving on to the last two satellites
unlike the first two sets which were
basically fully built by airbus
and boeing these two had more
involvement from the uae themselves
the mohamed bin rashid space center
would send engineers to south korea
and together they designed and built
device at 1
and device at 2. these two satellites
would end up launching in july of 2009
and november of 2013 respectively so
as you can see though the uae wasn't the
space power by any means
they did have a bit of experience
designing building and launching
satellites
anyway going back to the united arab
emirates space agency
after they were founded in 2014 they
would undertake
five main initiatives starting with the
online space science research center
this initiative is pretty
straightforward as the name suggests
they do research and development for
upcoming emirati space missions
aside from that they're also responsible
for forming partnerships with foreign
space powers
their second initiative was creating a
strong educational program
that would produce bright aerospace
engineers and rocket scientists
in may of 2015 oya satellite
communications company
the mossdart institute of science and
technology and orbital atk inc
signed a memorandum of understanding
this was basically just an agreement
that all three of these organizations
would teach and utilize the same set of
knowledge and skills
this would ensure a level of consistency
between their organizations
and streamline the process of switching
from academia to the workforce
this agreement also created a brand new
degree program in advanced space science
which was the first of its kind in the
middle east moving on
their third initiative was the emirates
mars mission and this
is where we hinted at at the beginning
of the video the responsibility of
designing
and building the mars hope probe was
given to dubai or more specifically the
mohammed bin rashid space center sheikh
mohammed bin rashid who is the ruler of
dubai
and the leader of the space center would
turn to the americans for some help
this mainly consisted of a couple of
universities including the university of
colorado boulder
arizona state university and the
university of california at berkeley
dubai also seeked help from india as
they had just successfully completed
their own mars orbiter mission called
mongolian one
for a record low cost of 74 million
dollars
with the help of india and a couple of
american universities
dubai started development of their hope
probe they first showed off a prototype
at the dubai air show in november of
at the time the project manager said
that they were still on track to launch
in july of 2020 but given that the
prototype was still in the early stages
of development
skeptics weren't quite convinced
nonetheless
dubai would successfully finish
construction of the space probe in
boulder colorado
and the probe would be transported to
its launch site in japan in april of
despite constraints due to the pandemic
the spacecraft would successfully be
launched in july of 2020
and reached mars in february of 2021.
clearly
the emiratis were not messing around and
this success
garnered international interest as to
what the uae will do next
and that brings us into the uae's fourth
initiative which is the emirates lunar
mission
this mission is actually extremely new
and was just announced in september of
sheikh mohammed bin rashid outlined that
the goal of the program
is to send a rover named rashid to the
moon in 2024
the rover will be designed to study the
thermal properties of the lunar surface
and analyze the composition of lunar
dust in microscopic detail
this project is also being led by the
muhammad bin rashid space center
and the sheikh hopes that this project
will allow the uae to subsequently send
a rover
to mars if the uae successfully
completes this mission
they would become the fourth country to
operate rover on the lunar surface
that is unless india beats them to the
moon
anyway moving on to the country's final
space initiative
we have space tourism the uae doesn't
have launch capability
nor do they plan to develop launch
capability anytime soon
but the uae has been a large supporter
of virgin galactic from very early on
in 2009 abu dhabi invested 280 million
dollars into version galactic
for 32 stake in the company and the uae
hopes to provide space tourism with the
help of virgin galactic
now i know a lot of you guys don't have
a very positive opinion
on virgin galactic as they have been
working on space tourism for
ages at this point but virgin galactic
did just complete their first human
spaceflight in late may
and there are rumors floating around
that richard branson is trying to beat
jeff bezos to space
so after all these years virgin galactic
is finally on the home stretch of
launching commercial space tourism
once all the final safety checks are
completed the uae
hopes to provide space tourism from
their online airport using the spaceship
too
the uae is already a mega hub within the
airline world
as they own both emirates and etihad so
hopefully they'll be able to transition
their airline success into space
as well all of that is great and all but
that still leaves a question
how was dubai able to nail mars on their
first try
while also sticking to their timeline
well this success can be explained by a
couple of notable factors
starting with launch capability the
hardest and longest part of launching a
satellite or probe is developing and
building the rocket itself but the uae
was able to completely skip this step by
relying on commercial launch providers
in their opinion developing new rockets
that don't push the envelope like
starship
is rather unproductive if you're not
going to develop new advanced rocket
technology
it makes more sense to just rely on
commercial launch providers instead of
making a meteor rocket
and the uae has fully embraced his
perspective aside from relying on
commercial launch providers
the uae has also had no problem in
forming international partnerships
and reaching out for help as we
discussed the uae has received help from
a handful of universities
bowling airbus korea india the uk and
france by seeking out the help of more
experienced players
the uae was able to heavily cut back on
trial and error
another major advantage that uae has is
their super young workforce
the average age of an engineer working
at the space agency
is just 27 years old and a young
workforce
is generally much more enthusiastic and
ambitious about the future
as they have much more to look forward
to during the apollo days the average
engineer at nasa was only 28 years old
so quite similar since then though the
average age of a nasa engineer has blown
to 45.8 years old
and that may be one of the key reasons
for nasa's lack of momentum
in recent years at the same time a young
workforce may suffer from a lack of
experience
however the uae's plethora of
partnerships with experienced
institutions
largely compensates for that so the uae
not only benefits from youth and
ambition but also
experience but more than all of this
there's
one key factor driving forward the uae
space effort
and that's survival over the past few
decades
the uae has heavily focused on
diversification and sustainability
you will see the uae and more
specifically abu dhabi
has historically been heavily dependent
on oil
and having all of your eggs in one
basket is not a good idea by any means
this is why the uae has been investing
so heavily into tourism
travel and business the space agency is
just a latest addition to this
diversification effort
now it's not like the uiu would go
bankrupt without the space agency
or anything like that but space is an
easy way to continue building the
country's reputation
and attracting more people to the
country people already think of the uae
as a leader in hospitality and tourism
thanks to the outstanding airlines
hotels and shopping centers wouldn't it
be awesome if people also thought of the
uae
as an innovative leader as well the uae
government
definitely thinks so and this has
motivated them to fully support the
agency in terms of both finance
and regulation in fact the uae has
already invested 5.2 billion dollars
into their space agency
this isn't stark contrast to the us
we're getting approval from congress and
the faa
takes forever full support from the uae
government has already done wondrous for
the country's airline and tourism
programs
maybe the space program is next do you
guys think the uae will become a space
leader
comment that down below also drop a like
if you look forward to seeing more
countries fully embrace space
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one